(whoosh)
(mouse click)
(digital jingle)
(soft piano music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape,
bipedal, naked, large-brained,
(soft piano music)
long the master of fire,
tools, and language,
but still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past.
Carta brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who
we are and how we got here,
an exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
(fanfare)
(synthesized jingle)
(soft digital music)
- Thank you.
It's a pleasure to be here
at this fabulous symposium.
I will be talking about mathematics,
and mathematics is perhaps
one of the most abstract,
complex, and precise
human conceptual systems ever invented.
Think about the Euclidean
point, for example.
It's an entity that has only
one property, that's location.
No extension whatsoever, so
no Euclidean point exists
really objectively in the universe,
and we have no biology to
perceive a Euclidean point,
yet the Euclidean point,
the humble little guy
is the cornerstone of the
edifice of Euclidean geometry
that led to Analytic geometry,
non-Euclidean geometries,
differential geometries, many
other fields in mathematics.
One area
that we could look at for the origins
of this fabulous human conceptual system
is abstracting its number.
To begin consider the following.
If you presented let's
say with this stimuli,
it's very easy for us to
discriminate between them,
but when the amount of dots
increases, it's not as easy,
and we make a few more mistakes,
and we make confusions.
Now, the capacity to discriminate
when there is only few of them
is called subitizing and is being studied
by experimental psychologists
since the 1940s.
This is an ability we don't
need to go to school to,
and we share with many other species.
Another ability is the following.
If we presented let's say
with these groups of dots,
black and white, when their
proportions differ considerably
it's very easy for us to
say which one has more
even though we may not
know exactly how many,
but we can tell.
When the proportions are
closer to each other,
it's a little harder and
sometimes very, very difficult.
This capacity is referred to
as Large Quantity Discrimination.
Now, these two capacities we share
with many other species as I was saying,
so this has led to many really to believe
that this is about now mathematics.
You would tend to see
many papers and chapters
and academic material talking about
monkey mathematical
abilities and kids in infancy
without schooling and arithmetic occurring
at a single-neuron level
and so on and so forth,
all the way to more recently
numerical cognition in
bees and other insects.
Now, of course, this is academia,
and then the media takes over and says,
well, like the New York Times here
science section earlier this year,
many animals can count,
some better than you,
and I know there's some
individuals in power now
who will also say the New York Times
report on fake news these days,
but that's not the only one.
Sometimes we see animals with tools
and kind of lead us to think that
there's some kind of
mathematical content involved,
or let's say this one,
(audience laughs)
fish as good as college
students in numbers test,
and mosquitofish can count
up to 100, count in quotes.
That whole thing as a
package in this society,
there's kind of a widely accepted view
that says there's a
biologically evolved capacity
that is specific for
number and arithmetic,
and I underlined here the word specific.
Now, of course, the question
is is it really the case?
And there's been some debate more lately,
and part of the issue is that
some of these terms are polysemous.
Number we use it for passport number,
telephone number, and many other things,
so what do we really mean by number?
And it turns out that in the literature,
the scientific literature
is permeated really
with underspecified
conceptions of what is numbers
such that we can describe
numerical and arithmetical
and mathematical capacities
to many other species.
Let's examine this a little bit more.
If we leave aside nonhuman
animals for a moment,
we can focus on human data
that has been overlooked.
For example, all known languages have
natural quantifiers like few,
several, many, and so on,
but by no means they all
exhibit exact quantification.
A recent study of about 200 languages
in aboriginal Australia from 13 different
linguistic families show that in fact
almost 90% of these languages
do not have a numeral
beyond what we would call five.
You can't in the cultures
speaking these languages refer to
seven or 12 or 19 or 23.
Now, similar research has been
found with hunter-gatherers
in Australia and Africa and South America,
and I strongly recommend also the book
by Caleb Everett that goes more in-depth
analyzing these particular cultures.
Now the point is here that
when we look at human language,
language by itself really does not lead
to number beyond the subitizing range,
so exact quantification seems to be
a cultural trait, not a biological trait.
How do we get from perceiving,
let's say, these dots
to labeling them as, let's
say, being nine or eight
whether with spoken words or with digits?
Well, when we do that we're involved
in what is called symbolic reference.
It's not just a purely
psychophysical perception anymore,
it's now another cognitive
activity like symbolic reference,
and we can do this with many other types
of numerals like in
Spanish nueve and ocho,
or we could do Roman
Numerals and other forms
and different bases in mathematics
or infinite decimal limitation
if you like and so on and so forth,
and there's another important property.
It's they are relational and operable.
My laptop computer here says number eight,
is that equivalent to the
product of two and four,
it's one more than seven and those things,
so they're all related to each other.
Really our familiar list one, two, three
has very specific abstract properties,
like it quantifies exactly,
not an approximate way,
and it is abstract in
sending stimulus modality,
visual or auditory.
It has a cardinal sense, an ordinal sense,
a relational property, which
is all combinative, operable,
and most importantly
referred to symbolically.
Number really is exact
symbolic quantification,
and this seems to be quite different
from what we observed, let's say,
with trained, by humans of course,
trained animals in the
lab where you can get,
for example, monkeys in
painstaking training,
four months, 20,000 trials
to discriminate dots
in a ratio three to four
only to 70% of accuracy.
It seems to be that we're
in a different realm here.
To summarize here we
can look at this figure.
Essentially what we have is
amount of discreet stuff,
let's say dots, going
from center to periphery,
increasing in amount.
What you see in your bottom left here,
what you have is subitizing a
large quantity discrimination,
the two abilities we just exercised
a little bit at the beginning,
and we share those with many species.
Now, with symbolic reference,
there's a symbolic gap there,
we can then label things
like natural quantifies
like many, few, and so on,
and then with exact
quantification we get it
to what you see clockwise there in blue,
which is now truly numerical.
The point is here what you see on the left
is really about quantity perception.
It's quantical abilities
are biologically endowed,
but in order to really get to number,
we need to go across
the symbolic reference
and that is not biologically evolvable.
Here I'm gonna borrow a
quote from Terry Deacon,
also a member of Carta, who says,
"Symbolic reference must
be acquired by learning,"
so this occurs in the
ontogeny of individuals,
"and lacks both the natural associations
"and trans-generational
reproductive consequences
"that would make such references
biologically evolvable."
So exact symbolic quantification
beyond the subitizing range
really needs a whole apparatus,
a culture that actually cares
about being exact and precise,
motivated by cultural preoccupations,
tracking valuables, trading,
accounting, and so on,
and is supported by and enhanced by tools
and off-loading cognition
which requires enculturation.
Of course, part of that comes,
and we heard already
previously about this,
the invention of writing
about 6,000 years ago
initially according to many
authors coming from tokens.
Tokens printed on envelope of clays,
eventually leading to clay tablets,
but you could also have
in the absence of writing,
for example, like the Inca did
with the use of the quipus,
performing amazingly sophisticated
calculations without writing,
or what you see in those
Shahinian Papua New Guinea
many groups you have now grammatical tools
in the language that could, for example,
codify certain types of morophemes
that would characterize
number of quantities
for counting things you care about.
For example, in this case
as you see in the picture,
yams in the culture Nen
worked on by Nick Evans.
What's in common there is that you need
a conventionalized symbolic reference
for exact quantification.
Now,
when there is number most number systems
are in base five or 10, and
you will say, "Why is that?"
Well, here we have a very handy tool
all the sudden in front of us.
You can identify fingers,
and we can sort of,
they're readily available.
That could explain part of it.
The issue is that gorillas, chimpanzees,
many species, raccoons,
they also are pentadactyl,
so they also have five fingers.
Evolution there giving
that particular form.
We have that.
We have brains that control
and get all the inputs, et cetera,
but what we don't have in this
case is symbolic reference,
the capacity to actually use
this as now potential tools,
which doesn't come with a handbook.
Cultural variations exist
in how you actually use
the hand for counting.
Here you have at the
top right number eight
being characterized bi-manually,
uni-manually, sometimes using the fingers,
sometimes using the finger joints.
Number eight if you use simple joints,
and the tip would be this, for example,
and so on in some cultures.
Now, when there is written
exact symbolic number,
it seems all this to be mediated
by culturally shaped cortical
phenotypical plasticity.
According to this work by Tang et al,
for example, they presented
digits to English speakers
and Chinese native speakers,
and they just asked to do
very simple calculations,
and what we observe is
very different recruitment
for neural populations in the two groups.
You see more recruitment
in the left hemisphere
perisylvian area in the
English speakers and much
let's say more in premotor
regions for the Chinese speakers.
Number then really what we
have is a language mediated,
conventionalized exact
symbolic quantification,
which is a cultural trait,
and this occurring quite, quite recently
and largely outside of
biological evolution.
It builds on biologically
evolved pre-conditions.
We need subitizing in large
quantity discrimination,
but themselves they not
mathematical or numerical.
These are motivated by cultural
preoccupations as I said,
supported crucially by
material and conceptual tools
and the biology that makes
enculturation possible.
I wanna take this now to the next step.
Once we have numbers we can start creating
all kinds of other things.
One, a very ubiquitous, powerful
tool is the number line,
which now we need another system,
which is to conceive numbers
as locations in space,
metaphorically if you will.
Now this, of course, many
of the talks before this one
we're using graphs to
characterize amounts and so on,
it's helpful for reading economic graphs
and look at scientific data
or develop vector spaces
and fancy visualizations and so on.
What is interesting is that these days
this is learned or
presented in kindergarten.
Kindergartens already start to see
little bunnies jumping back and forth,
and froggies doing jumping,
jumps and so on and so forth.
This has led a lot of people
to think that perhaps we have,
again, a biologically
endowed mental number line,
which is housed in the
intraparietal sulcus
of the human brain.
Well, that's true if you
only look at westerners
who already went to school
and know how these work.
A lot of papers support the idea
that you would have very
spontaneous mappings
occurring in infants, in macaques,
and more recently a paper in Science
saying that newborn chicks now,
so go figure what kind of
cortex they would have,
would actually have a mental
number line like humans.
Now, if that were really the case,
let's cross that with
some other type of data.
For example, we would expect culture,
number savvy cultures
like Babylonia, let's say,
to have some manifestation of number lines
somewhere in all the
number crunching they did.
Well, when you look at
half a million tablets
that we know today, there's
not a single number line there.
That says something.
They did a lot of numbers
without a number line.
In fact you have to go to 17th century.
It's not even in La
Geometrie by Rene Descartes,
who invented analytic geometry.
Not a single number line there either.
The first appears to be John Napier
when he is introducing of logarithms,
a very sophisticated
notion, and he is saying,
"Okay, here is a line.
"We're gonna start thinking this way."
But the first who does an operational
use of a number line is John Wallis,
and here if you really look
at the text, he says, okay,
talking, the audience
is la creme de la creme,
the top of the top of mathematicians
in Europe in 17th century saying,
"Think of a man walking five steps
"and then walking two back,
"and that's gonna be five
minus two equals three."
That's what you hear today
in a kindergarten class,
but this is now a few
hundred years ago in Europe.
We also wanted to test
how spontaneous is this?
We went and we did a study
among the Yupno of Papua New Guinea,
and we presented a line
segment, following other methods
that had been introduced in the Amazon,
and we could see that, for example,
even though they had numbers
to at least 20 in numerals,
they essentially mapped small numbers
on one end and bigger to the other end
whether it was dots or
tones or other things
unlike the school Yupno
and California Control's
as you see on the right side.
The red one being the unschooled
using only the extremes.
No use of the path whatsoever,
which is required for the number line.
The intuition doesn't seem to be,
again, universal in that sense.
What do we do with these abstractions?
Well, we do crazy things.
Of course we have the mathematicians
very recently developing it,
but today it's introduced
in the kindergarten class,
but this could be taken
to further directions
to develop the notions of hyperreal lines.
All the sudden now the
number line on the real line,
which is now housing irrational
numbers and rational numbers
and by virtue of the
least-upper-bound axiom,
you have a complete ordered field.
No more dots could fit in there.
Well, you can when you go
to non-Euclidean numbers,
infinitely tiny, infinitely small numbers,
the epsilons you see there,
or huge numbers, their
reciprocals, the omegas,
that are bigger and larger
than any real number.
Then you start to have
embedded, mutually incompatible,
non-commensurable number lines embedded
in infinitely many spots in
infinitely many of these lines.
All this going back to
the simple number line
that we develop a few hundred years ago.
Really the story of numbers
and tools in mathematics
can be reduced to this process
of enculturation where you do
need a biological apparatus
that would support it.
I would like to close with this quote,
and I thank Pascal Gagneux for pointing me
to this one by geneticist
and evolutionary biologist
Theodosius Dobzhansky who said,
"Human evolution has two components,
"the biological or organic,
"and the cultural or superorganic.
"These components are
neither mutually exclusive
"nor independent, but
interrelated and interdependent.
"Human evolution cannot be understood
"as a purely biological process,
"nor can it be adequately
described as a history of culture.
"It is the interaction
of biology and culture,"
and I think mathematics
exemplifies this perfectly well.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
(lively digital music)